c'est fort une rencontre avec henri
vernes son nom ne vous dit sans doute
pas grand chose mais son personnage lui
est très connu il s'agit de bob morane
avec ses 93 printemps déjà le créateur
de l'aventurier publie ses mémoires
christelle sabarots et jean luc douchet
l'aventurier c'est lui il a été boxeur
journaliste espions diamantaire il a
parcouru le monde et henri vernes est
toujours revenu à bruxelles là il y
avait le petit café le plus mal famé de
bruxelles
hélas il n'existe plus le père de bob
morane a aujourd'hui 93 ans est toujours
envie de profiter de la vie une vie
liées à celles de son héros qu'il
retrouve dans ce bar du quartier des
sablons
voilà est chassé bob morane dans le fond
je ne sais pas jean-claude pourquoi qui
est installé bob morane ichi pas si
l'exercice
viens ici parce qu'il a rendez vous avec
l'héroïne nathalie est alors l'histoire
s'est déroulée ici et le mode horde or
les attend en haut dans la rue des mines
et bien oui tout neuf mois mois toute
mon adolescence a été bercée par heure
je ne savais pas que j'allais devenir un
jour son ami mon dieu et puis toute mon
adolescence le pire à henri vernes eux
n'est pas auteur de bd
il est écrivain bob morane est né sous
sa plume en 1953 dans des romans
jeunesse écrit à la demande d'un éditeur
60 ans et 200 livres plus tard l'auteur
contemple avec plaisir cette vie parti
dans tous les sens je n'ai jamais vécu
la vie chez un implant j'ai voulu être
marin j'ai voulu être aviateurs je n'ai
pas été ma rage n'est pas pierre viateur
j'ai été diamantaire ça n'a pas duré
longtemps
je fais autre chose ma vie n'est pas du
tout structuré c'est un gigantesque des
arbres et c'est pour ça finalement
qu'elle est intéressante
une vie de voyages et de rencontres qui
a inspiré les aventures de son héros bob
morane un gaillard avec lequel
l'écrivain entretient des relations
houleuses et jette un compagnon de vue
humain compagnon fort envoyé ça parce
que quelquefois je lui me prier à lui
alors que je n'avais pas envie parce que
j'étais tenu évidemment pas fournir mes
textes
adael que jma régulière voulait pas
forcément méthodes en aurait pas une
maison dont je suis membre du bob morane
a beau avoir éternellement 33 ans il a
tout de même vieilli et au centre belge
de la bd
il est à peine présenté n'empêche le
héros à ses fans les enfants des années
50 et 60 qui continue d'entretenir le
nom
brahms et un peu indiana jones avant la
lettre
vous voyez les aventures d'indiana jones
c'est pourquoi il ya eu cinq aventures
de manquer et qui sont la science
fiction c'est même je défends tu as tes
tous les thèmes du fantastique sont son
sont énumérés dans ces sacrements et
pour moi ça a été le déclic nous
deuxième déclic où j'ai retrouvé votre
moral
dans ses mémoires henri vernes raconte
surtout son enfance et sa jeunesse il a
donc prévu de reprendre bientôt la plume
de voudrais faire un récit un peu
semblable sur mes voyages et je voudrais
encore faire un bon moral
ce dernier peut-être où l'avant-dernier
étrangères
[Musique]